[Musique]
il s'agit d'un projet de groupe scolaire
école maternelle école élémentaire avec
une salle de sport un accueil
périscolaire une bibliothèque et donc la
responsabilité qu'on a dans ce projet
c'est de créer un lieu un lieu pour pour
la pédagogie et je dirais un lieu
bienveillant on a un contraste entre
l'intérieur très ludique et puis
l'extérieur plus sobre en extérieur qui
s'adresse à la ville en a mis l'accent
sur les transparences c'est un bâtiment
qui est très ouvert sur sur la place
notamment l'idée c'est de proposer un
lieu pour une pédagogie ouverte pour une
pédagogie en mouvement le chantier est
un chantier très court 17 mois et le
bâtiment est prévue pour une livraison
en 2019 donc septembre 2019 dans norrath
20 classes
les premières ambitions du parc était
faire une liaison entre les différents
bâtiments qui sont autour
le parc il ya une diagonale qui est
intégrer il ya une place centrale qui
est en passe à côté du super mec
donc il ya en fait deux lieux un peu
différent un lieu qui a plus rien qui se
lier entre les bâtiments un lieu qui a
plu et présente qui est pour la détente
pour être dans la nature dans un
quartier qui est affaibli namik un
quartier de payer par des bâtiments
scolaires étudiants et par des logements
pour le quartier un sujet important pour
le parc est aussi la sécurité dans le
quartier il ya un plan hydraulique
ça veut dire qu'on veut éviter avec des
grands crus que il ya un problème
d'inondation pour ça le parc les espaces
publics jouent un rôle important et en
partie du parc dans leur concept pris
compte que c'est possible a demandé et
on peut dire que le petit parcours qui
croise le parc on peut voir commune
rivière sèche qui devient inondées avec
les grands crus et qui trouve sa fin
dans les temps dans le bout du parc
[Musique]